Mình đợi thêm 10 phút nữa,
lớp mình vào đủ rồi bắt đầu học luôn hả
các em?
Rồi mình bắt đầu hả kem.
Báo cáo là báo cáo tiến trình,
nó sẽ báo cáo theo đợt chứ mình không có
báo cáo nhỏ lẻ từng đợt lại nha các em.
Hai hiện tại là mình còn một cái buổi
hướng dẫn trước khi hôm nay là buổi thứ.
Tôi có con hôm nay của thứ mấy rồi.
Hôm nay là buổi thứ 7 thì mình còn tới 1
còn 1 buổi sau.
Một buổi 8 để.
Khoan để cô coi lại chính xác.
A plan của mình.
À, mình còn 1 buổi 8,
buổi 8 là để hoàn thiện các cái nội dung
còn lại và nhóm nào còn chỗ nào không rõ
thì mình trao đổi hết.
Những cái này không giúp ý,
hôm trước thì mình sửa tiếp.
Nhóm 10 thí dụ cái trang có bữa chỗ em
sửa chỗ nào không rõ thì em cao rồi hỏi
và cuối giờ những nội dung đó thôi hát em.
Rồi hôm nay mình học tiếp.
Hồi hôm nay mình sẽ học tiếp khai trương
chương nội dung chương này của mình,
nó cũng không quá khó và cho các em các
khái niệm cơ bản để mình hiểu rõ hơn các
thành phần trong cơ sở thông tin.
Đấy lúc mà mình viết cái đề án đầu tư thì
mình biết là mình nên đầu tư các thiết bị
và thành phần nào thôi.
Còn sao nội dung chương thì cô sẽ đi tiếp
cái phần hướng dẫn thực hành và hướng dẫn
đồ án cho các buổi tiếp theo.
Làm bài tập về nhà.
Rồi về cái phần nội dung chương 5 là mình
sẽ học về tài nguyên mạng và các cái dịch
vụ mạng cơ bản.
Thì trong cái thành phần đầu tư của mình
mình có cái thành phần này ha nên mình sẽ
nắm các khái niệm cơ bản để mình.
Cũng bị nhầm đầu tiên là mình sẽ tìm hiểu
về các khái niệm mạng như là mạng nội bộ
thì mạng này khá là quen thuộc với mình.
Ha mạng nội bộ là mạng kết nối các cái
thiết bị trong phạm vi nhỏ.
Ví dụ như là phòng làm việc nè,
lớp học văn phòng và tòa nhà nhằm cho
phép các thiết bị này có thể trao đổi dữ
liệu nè, dùng chung máy in,
máy chủ internet và giúp cho cái a-min
quản lý tập trung luôn.
Thì đối với các cái mạng nội bộ này này á
nó có đặc điểm thì tốc độ thường cao,
chi phí triển khai hợp lý và nó an toàn.
Tại vì gồm có cách mạng nội bộ với nhau
thôi,
nếu không cái mạng nội bộ này nếu không
kết nối với mạng internet bên ngoài nha
thì thường mạng.
Nó bỏ nó sẽ an toàn hơn.
Cái mạng nội bộ này thường được triển
khai trong các cái mạng phòng máy của
trường, mạng trong công ty,
mạng Wi-Fi và gia đình.
Thường trong công ty đều sẽ có các mạng
nội bộ này để hoạt động một số phần mềm
thì nó sẽ đòi hỏi đồ bảo mật cao.
Lúc mình thiết kế, lúc mình có sự lỗi,
lúc mình thiết kế thì mình đang đứng đóng
vai trò là thiết kế thì mình sẽ thiết kế
cái mạng nội bộ trong công ty.
Còn về internet thì quen thuộc ra ha là
cái hệ thống kết nối.
Để thiết bị trên toàn thế giới thì các
cái khi mà mình kết nối internet thì nó
sẽ chung cho mình cung cấp nhiều dịch vụ
khác nhau từ web,
email hoặc trực tuyến video rồi lưu trữ
đám mây, vân vân.
Thì internet á theo cái mình phải hiểu là
nó không phải là một mạng duy nhất mà nó
sẽ là màu nhiều mạng liên kết với nhau.
Nhiều mảng liên kết với nhau và các cái.
Khi mà mình liên kết với số lượng lớn như
vậy á thì đương nhiên mình sẽ phải có cái
biện pháp để phân biệt giữa các cái thiết,
các cái điểm mạng,
các thiết bị trên mạng internet nên
thường mình sẽ nghe tới cái khái niệm là
địa chỉ IP nè.
Và mình phải có các thiết bị trung gian
để mình kiểm soát các cái lưu lượng từ
máy mình đi ra cái mạng internet bên
ngoài chung thì đối với các cái địa chỉ
IP này thường.
Mình học không học chuyên ngành học sâu
về mạng thì mình sẽ.
Không ít tiếp xúc thường người dùng thì
người ta sẽ truy cập thông qua các cái
tên miền, tên miền nhiều hơn.
Còn cái địa chỉ,
địa chỉ này là khi mà mình.
Học sau về mạng máy tính và truyền thông
thì mình sẽ học về cái địa chỉ IP này
cách cái cách phát địa chế IP và hiện tại
thì có nhiều cái thiết bị để hỗ trợ và
cấp phát địa chỉ IP tự động ha.
Thì cái địa chỉ IP của mình thì nó cũng
giống như địa chỉ nhà giúp nhận biết
thiết bị khi tham gia vào mạng,
và mỗi thiết bị khi kết nối mạng thì
thường sẽ có một cái địa chỉ IP.
Đây là cái địa chỉ IP thường để truy vết
và.
Các cái nhà cung cấp mạng sẽ có thể quản
lý được hết nha,
có thể là mình đăng nhập ẩn danh,
nhưng mà mình đi ra bằng cái thiết bị của
mình cũng phải có một cái địa chỉ IP nên
thường người ta sẽ vẫn điều truy ra hết
cái địa chỉ IP của mình được hết.
Thì IB nó cũng sẽ có nhiều loại IB khác
nhau, gồm có IB nội bộ, nè, IB công cộng,
IB tỉnh và AB động.
Cái IP tỉnh IP động này nó sẽ được tùy
theo cái mục tiêu xây dựng sử dụng như là
nếu của mình là máy chủ camera thiết bị
quản trị ít thay đổi thì mình sẽ có một
cái IP tỉnh. Còn.
IB động thì nó thường được tự động theo
cái máy của người dùng.
Và ở đây nó có 2 loại IB,
2 loại IB nội bộ và công cộng.
Cái này nếu mà bạn nào từng tham gia tiết
mình có nhiều thiết bị nội bộ trong phòng
làm việc mình kết nối thì mình đã sẽ tiếp
xúc với IB nội bộ này rồi.
Phải kết nối trực tiếp thông qua thiết bị
bằng cái địa chỉ nội bộ.
Nhưng mà bắt buộc phải truy cập trong
cuộc mạng thì mới thấy nhau và thiết kế
được, mới liên kết được ha.
Còn về cái mô hình kết nối á thì mình cái
này thì cái này là cái mà mình cần nắm.
Nhiều hơn nè,
các thiết bị kết nối này là các cái thiết
bị mà thường á là nó sẽ là những cái
thiết bị mà mình cần phải đầu tư trong
cái công ty của mình.
Đầu tiên là các em sẽ phải có cái thiết
bị đầu cuối.
Mình phải có đầy đủ các thiết bị đầu cuối
cho những người dùng như là máy tính,
điện thoại, máy in, camera.
Ngoài ra thì mình sẽ có các cái thiết bị
mạng trung gian,
các lát mà mình sẽ tìm hiểu kỹ hơn cái
này ha.
Rồi có phải có phải xây dựng đường điện
cách mạng.
Mạng và có cái máy chủ và các dịch vụ để
điều phối thì một cái luồng đơn giản là
mình sẽ có thiết bị bị người dùng thông
qua Switch router thì nó sẽ đến in mạng
internet hoặc là máy chủ nội bộ.
Thì đối với các thiết kế mạng,
cái nhóm nó có nhiều thành phần liên kết
với nhau,
nhưng nó cũng sẽ có nhiều mô hình kết nối
khác nhau, ha.
Thì ở đây là tụi mình sẽ có 2 cái loại
thông dụng là mô hình kết nối mạng ngang
hàng là các máy.
Chủ sẽ chia sẻ trực tiếp với nhau phù hợp
cho mạng nhỏ, đơn giản,
dễ triển khai nhưng khó quản lý khi số
lượng lớn.
Có một công nghệ đang cố gắng xây dựng
mạng YouTube theo số lượng lớn là cái bên
công nghệ blockchain á.
Là đang muốn xây dựng cái mạng theo cái
số lượng lớn Metubi này để giảm thiểu sự
phụ thuộc của bên thứ 3.
Còn cái mạng clan server của mình là có
máy dạng theo máy khách, máy chủ,
có nghĩa là máy khách gửi yêu cầu đến máy
chủ.
Máy chủ cung cấp dữ liệu dịch vụ và phù
hợp cho tổ chức, doanh nghiệp, trường học.
Thường thì người ta sẽ công ty thì nó sẽ
đi theo cái mô hình clan server này.
Nhưng mà nó sẽ có một cái,
hai cái mô hình này,
cái nào nó cũng sẽ có ưu nhược điểm riêng.
Cái này nó sẽ không phụ thuộc vào bên thứ
ba,
còn cái này nó sẽ phụ thuộc vào bên thứ
ba.
Phụ thuộc vào bên thứ ba có nghĩa là sẽ
có nghĩa là.
Dữ liệu của mình có được đảm bảo quyền
riêng tư hay không,
có được bảo mật hay không?
Nó sẽ phụ thuộc vào cái máy chủ của mình.
Là cái bên thứ ba quản lý máy chủ á.
Đã quản lý máy chủ thì người ta sẽ nắm
được hết tất cả thông tin.
Và đương nhiên là nếu họ sử dụng các
thông tin mình không đúng thì có thể là
sau này là có các cái quy định về an ninh
mạng sẽ có giá trị pháp lý,
nhưng mà nói chung xử lý nó sẽ khó ha và
khi mà mình chấp nhận đi theo cái máy chủ
clanserver này thì bắt buộc.
Là mình phải chấp nhận là mình phải cung
cấp thông tin cho người ta và cái thông
tin mình nó.
Nó có an ninh bảo mật hay không sẽ phụ
thuộc vào bên đó quản lý.
Nếu mà chẳng may mà nó người ta sử dụng
cái thông tin.
Của mình và mục đích khác thì mình sẽ
phải gặp nhiều khó khăn để mình xử lý cái
phần này.
Đó là khuyết điểm chính nên thường đó là
người ta **** muốn là xây dựng nghiên cứu
nguồn công nghệ để có thể một cái mạng
hay là một hệ thống có thể vận hành.
Mà nó không phụ thuộc quá nhiều vào máy
chủ,
hoặc là giảm sự ảnh hưởng của cái máy chủ
là cái của bên thứ 3 đó và mọi người có
thể mà nó có thể tự vận hành.
Hồi đó là một số cái khái niệm cơ bản về
mạng,
còn các thiết bị mạng cơ bản hồi nãy mình
nhắc ở trên như là SWIFT, Browter,
Fiwire á thì mình sẽ đi theo đi từng cái
Swift thì dùng để kết nối nhiều thiết bị
trong cái mạng LAN của mình. Mạng Len nào,
mạng nội bộ ha?
Nó sẽ giúp mở rộng số lượng thiết bị kết
nối,
tăng hiệu quả truyền dữ liệu trong nội bộ,
thường dùng trong phòng máy,
văn phòng và hệ thống camera.
Thì các em phải hình dung là khi một cái
mô hình hệ thống của mình mà có quá nhiều
thành phần tham gia.
Da thì bắt buộc phải có bên hệ thống kết
nối và quản lý chứ không thì nó sẽ không
vận hành được ha.
Hình như là mít của bạn nào đang mở.
Do tác mất của bạn,
mít của một số bạn đang mở nha.
Để mình không có việc tập anh.
Còn đối với trong tơ thì nó sẽ dùng để
kết nối mạng nội bộ với internet hoặc
giữa nhiều mạng với nhau,
năng chính của mình giúp định tuyến đường
truyền dữ liệu và chọn đường đi phù hợp
cho gói tin.
Nó sẽ giúp mình bắt wifi nè cấp phát kết
nối internet kết hợp với một số chức năng
quản lý cơ bản cái.
Phương thức hoạt động của Switch Router
này mình có cái video,
cái video này cũng cũ rồi,
về cách mà các cô tin được truyền riêng
đi với nhau như thế nào.
Các tín hiệu á tín hiệu nó và đảm bảo sao
các cái tín hiệu được truyền tới nó sẽ
không bị mất.
Nếu bị mất thì nó sẽ có cơ chế để truyền
lại để đảm bảo thông tin của mình,
nó không bị thiếu á thì cái này hiện tại
thì nó theo con đường hiện tại nó không
còn bị lỗi chứ trước đây thì mấy cái này
nó cũng cần một cái thời gian để phát
triển ha.
Bây giờ thì sử dụng thoải mái rồi,
còn về cái firewall thì nó sẽ khác với 2
cái thành phần, 2 cái thiết bị trên,
nó là cái thiết bị phần mềm hoặc là cái
phần mềm dùng để cái mình kiểm soát lưu
lượng ra vào chặn truy cập tới khoét và
tăng an toàn mạng.
Và trái phép và tăng.
Sao cái bạn nào mà dùng?
Kem son vô là kem nhớ tắt mức nha kem.
Quay lại thì nó sẽ giúp mình ngăn các cái
chặn các truy cập trái phép và tăng an
toàn mạng. Thì ở đây nó sẽ cũng có cái.
Đặc biệt.
Bạn nào thấy?
À rồi quay lại nếu trong các lớp đầu tư
của các em và có thành phần mạng mà các
em cần phải đầu tư thì các em cần phải
đầu tư đầy đủ các cái lên cái này là nó
sẽ đơn giản là mình phải xác định cái
phạm vi.
Khi mà mình đầu tư cho bao nhiêu,
nếu người dùng và cho các quy trình hoạt
động nào thì mình sẽ đầu tư cái dựa vào
cái lượng tương tác và cái lượng truy cập
á thì dự kiến thì mình sẽ đầu tư các
thiết bị này phù hợp và mình sẽ đầu tư
luôn cả.
Thiết bị để kiểm soát cái lưu lượng ra
vào và chặn truy cập trái phép bên là bao
gồm cả thiết bị phần mềm và các thiết bị
phần cứng cho cái phần tài nguyên mạng
này luôn ha.
Thì về so sánh thì các em có thể hiểu cơ
bản.
Switch thì dùng để kết nối mạng nội bộ,
còn router thì để lên tuyến liên mạng và
fiver thì dùng để bảo vệ ha.
Way firewall thì nó ở đây thường á thì.
Đối với cái máy tính cá nhân thì mình hay
nghe tới phần mềm tường lửa,
nhưng mà đối với các cái.
Cơ quan và công ty lớn thì thường mình sẽ
có cả thiết bị firewall để hỗ trợ cho cái
này luôn ha,
và mình sẽ phải mua bỏ chi phí đi mua nữa
ha.
Còn đối với các dịch vụ nền,
dịch vụ nền này là các dịch vụ để hỗ trợ
mình nhiều hơn trong phần tài nguyên mạng
này để có thể vận hành.
Như là DNS là nó sẽ giúp mình chuyển tên
miền thành địa chỉ IP vì.
Theo các địa chỉ IP, nó giống như hồi nãy,
cô nói đó mình sẽ có cái danh bạ để giúp
mình dễ nhớ hơn.
Còn đi HCB thì nó sẽ cấp KP tự động cho
các thiết bị kết nối mạng để giảm các cấu
hình thủ công và tránh trùng lắp địa chỉ
IP.
Địa chỉ IP nó giống như cái địa chỉ định
danh của mình nó trơn của các thành phần
khi tham thiết bị.
Khi mà tham gia vào cái hệ thống mạng,
còn VPN thì VPN thì nó sẽ là giúp mình
tạo kết nối an toàn giữa người dùng và
mạng đích của qua internet để bảo vệ dữ
liệu phi truyền nè,
truy cập tài nguyên nội bộ từ xa và tăng
tính riêng tư trong một số.
Tình huống cái này nó giống như là một số
cái ứng dụng mà cô nói là mạng não bộ nó
an toàn á thì.
Ở có một số cái dịch vụ,
nó sẽ chỉ cho phép truy cập và sử dụng
trong trường hợp mà khi em đang ở trong
mạng nội bộ thôi.
Cái này ví dụ giống như ở trường thì cũng
có một cái số hệ thống máy ảo thực nghiệm.
Mở ra cho sinh viên xài thì cái hệ thống
máy học của trường của mình là để đảm bảo
an ninh mạng,
không có bị hệ thống bên ngoài sử dụng.
Hay người bên ngoài mà chưa được cấp
quyền sử dụng và để cam giảm nhiệm vụ tấn
công thì thường quy định là các bạn sinh
viên muốn truy cập vào hệ thống máy ảo
của trường thì phải sử dụng ở mạng nội bộ
trường,
có nghĩa là các bạn có thể ở trường.
Các bạn làm học ở trường rồi các bạn truy
cập trực tiếp vào.
Còn nếu mà các bạn ở nhà thì mình làm từ
xa,
thì mình truy gặp bằng cách nào thì mình
sẽ sử dụng VPN này đó,
VPN để giúp mình truy cập mạng nội bộ từ
xa an toàn hơn thôi.
Thì lợi ích của nó sẽ giúp mình mã hóa
lưu lượng, hỗ trợ làm việc từ xa,
hạn chế các rủi ro khi dùng wifi công
cộng và các tình huống sử dụng như là các
em muốn truy cập tài liệu nội bộ công ty
nè, quản trị hệ thống từ xa.
Toàn như các chi nhánh và trụ sở.
Thì cái này nó giống như cái dịch vụ VVN
này giống như là trong cái phần đầu tư là
mình cũng có thể suy nghĩ là mình muốn
cần phải cấu hình cái VPN này cho hệ
thống công ty của mình hay không á và mục
tiêu.
Khi mà mình làm cái này là các em cần
phải giám sát kết nối trong việc theo dõi
thì mạng nó có đang để mình biết là mạng
mình có đang hoạt động không.
Tốc độ có ổn định không,
có mất gói nhãn mạng hay không,
để mình giúp mình phát hiện sự cứu sớm,
nâng cao độ.
Ổn định và hỗ trợ quản trị mạng,
cái này nó sẽ đi đôi với cái an ninh.
Quản trị và an ninh.
Thì các cái nội dung mà thường khi mà
theo dõi đối với các hệ thống giám sát
này thì người ta sẽ theo dõi hệ trạng
thái thiết bị nè, băng thông,
độ trễ và tỉ lệ mất kết nối để mình kiểm
tra cái vì sao bạn chậm ha?
Ở đây là một số cách giám sát kết nối.
Cơ bản.
Cần có thể tham khảo về tổng kết về cái
phần nội dung này làm.
Mình phải có các khái niệm cơ bản về mạng
nội bộ và internet nè về địa chỉ IB,
các cái thiết bị quan trọng mình cần phải
đầu tư trong cái phần tài nguyên mạng này
và một số cái dịch vụ mình thường sử dụng.
Và bắt buộc là mình phải có cái cơ chế để
giám sát kết nối mạng để đảm bảo an toàn
thì những nhóm nào mà có sử dụng cái
thành phần này đầu tư cái thành phần này
trong cái đề án.
Đồ em khoa học của mình á thì các em có
thể tham khảo các khái niệm cơ bản này để
mình xác định cái số lượng các cái thiết
bị hoặc những thành phần mạng nào mình
cần đầu tư để phù hợp với công ty hoặc cơ
quan đó.
Rồi đây là những cái khái niệm cơ bản về
của trong chương 5 các em có chỗ nào
không rõ không?
Sao Huy.
Cầu vàng đó bắt lộn rồi đâu mất tiêu rồi.
Còn nếu không có câu hỏi của phần chương
này thì mình sẽ đi tới chương tiếp theo,
chương tiếp theo quan trọng hơn.
Nhưng tiếp theo của mình là cái chương mà
mình có vận dụng nhiều hơn trong và nó có
liên quan tới cái bài tập giao về nhà
ngày hôm nay.
Ừ, ok, cô thấy rồi nha Huy.
Rồi mình sẽ tới chương tiếp theo là
chương 6 Quảng Trị thống và vận hành hạ
tầng.
Đầu tiên muốn quản trị đương nhiên mình
sẽ phải nắm các nguyên tắc quản trị ha
thì nó sẽ có các nguyên tắc quản trị khác
nhau.
Đầu tiên là mình phải quản lý được người
dùng,
thì người dùng quản lý người dùng là quá
trình tạo, cập nhật, tạm ngưng và thu.
Ngồi tài khoản theo vòng đời sử dụng.
Cái này là khi mà mình cấp quyền cho
người dùng,
mình phải đặt cái mục tiêu là mình phải
cấp quyền cho đúng cho người dùng,
đúng thời điểm,
đúng phạm vi sử dụng và dễ kiểm soát truy
vết. Nếu có vấn đề xảy ra, tránh cấp sót.
Cái cấp cái quyền sai hay là cấp quyền
vượt quá cái quyền hạn của cái người đó,
hoặc là giống như thí dụ giống như giảng
viên với sinh viên trong trường mình cấp
quyền cho sinh viên chỉ có thể xem điểm
và cấp quyền cho giảng viên.
Chỉ có là có thể nhập điểm nhưng cũng chỉ
có thể nhập điểm các môn phụ trách thôi
và mình không có thể nào đảo ngược là
mình nếu mà mình xác định cái quyền sai
và cách cái quyền nhập điểm cho sinh viên
thì nó là sai rồi á thì cái nó sẽ gây ra
cái vấn đề về bảo mật.
Của cái hệ thống không đảm bảo hệ thống
được bảo mật và đáng tin cậy.
Á và các cái nhóm người dùng thường gặp á
thường khi mà mình cấp phát á thì mình sẽ
thấy có nhóm nhân viên nội bộ,
quản trị viên đối tác nhà cung cấp và các
cái tài khoản dịch vụ.
Phủ thì cái nguyên tắc cơ bản khi mình
cấp phát đối với việc để đảm bảo quản lý
người dùng thì mỗi người dùng sẽ có tài
khoản riêng và khi mà người ta đăng nhập
bằng cái tài khoản riêng đó rồi thì nó sẽ
giúp mình định danh được.
Đây là cái hành động của cái hành động
của cái tài khoản này chính là hành động
của cái người dùng đó và mình phải chịu
trách nhiệm với cái hành động đó đó em
thì cái này.
Nếu mà ai mà học về IT hiểu rõ về vấn đề
này thì mình sẽ giảm được cái việc mà
mình bị lừa đảo á,
em trong một số các nguyên cái việc mà
phương thức lừa đảo thì có một phương
thức lừa đảo là hãy cái thông tin của
mình.
Đang bị sai hoặc là mình đang bị vấn đề
gì đó và nhân viên của cái công ty đó nó
yêu cầu mình cung cấp tài khoản và
password của mình cho họ để họ vào hệ
thống.
Họ hiệu chỉnh giúp mình.
Thì nếu mà ai không quen hoặc là không
rạch thì người ta có thể dễ bị dính cái
bẫy đó.
Nhưng mà nếu mà ai học về cái IT thì mình
sẽ hiểu rõ vấn đề này thứ nhất.
Là cái tài khoản riêng của mình sẽ tương
với mỗi người dùng và nó sẽ đại diện cho
mình nên cái hành động của tài khoản đó
đang làm gì trên hệ thống thì nó sẽ tương
đương với cái việc mình đang làm gì đó
trên hệ thống.
Và cái thứ 2 là cái cấp phát quyền này là
cái quyền mà trên hệ thống thực chất là
admin cấp quyền cho mình có làm được gì
hay không và quyền đó là thực chất chắc
chắn là admin hoặc là những người có
quyền cấp cao hơn sẽ có thể làm được cái
thao tác, những cái.
Tác của cái những người dùng quyền cấp
thấp,
ví dụ giống như giảng viên của sinh viên
thì giảng viên,
đương nhiên có quyền cao hơn sinh viên và
sinh viên có quyền xem điểm thì đương
nhiên giảng viên cũng có quyền xem điểm.
Chỉ có cái là giảng viên có quyền nhập
điểm sinh viên không có quyền nhập điểm
thôi.
Thì kem có thể dụ giống như tài khoản
ngân hàng đi.
Mình thì chỉ có thể xem được cái thông
tin tài khoản ngân hàng của mình và thực
hiện cái thao tác bên trong mình thôi.
Nhưng nhân viên ngân hàng có quyền quyền
hơn ha có nhiều thì không có cái lý do gì
mà.
Cái cần phải có tài khoản của mình thì họ
mới làm được.
Áp lên đường nhiên chắc chắn sẽ phải có
những tài khoản cấp cao toàn quyền xử lý
tất cả các vấn đề có thể xảy ra khi hệ
thống đang vận hành.
Chứ không thể nào đợi có cái tài khoản
của mình rồi họ vào cái tài khoản của
mình thì họ mới xử lý được thì chuyện đó
không có thể không có.
Sẽ ra,
còn nếu mình trao cái quyền đó đi cho
người ta có nghĩa là mình đang chấp nhận
mình đang hà làm cái hành động đó,
ví dụ giống như cái hành động chuyển
khoản đi thường thì nếu mà mình dùng tài
khoản của mình chuyển đi thì.
Nó sẽ giống như cái hành động là mình
đang dùng cái thông tin của mình mình
chuyển đi và chấp nhận.
Còn nhân viên thực thực thực chấp nhân
viên ngân hàng cũng có thể thực hiện
chuyển khoản giúp mình nếu mình ủy quyền
nhưng mà khi nhân viên làm cái chuyện đó
thì mình có cái thông tin ủy quyền thì nó
sẽ đảm bảo.
Còn cái việc này mình cung cấp cho người
ta rồi người ta tự động làm cái gì đó mà
mình không kiểm soát được thì thường thì
lừa đảo,
nó sẽ bị đánh vô cái chỗ này ha nên cái
chỗ mà.
Khi mà mình xây dựng cái hệ thống phần
mềm cho người dùng thì mình hay đi nó đi,
có lại là cái thông tin này,
thông tin cá nhân không có được quyền cho
cung cấp cho bất kỳ ai ngay cả bên quản
lý. Tại vì người ta dùng.
Cũng là cái thao tác đó,
nhưng mà quên quang lý quản lý làm cho
mình.
Hay là mình tự làm thì nó sẽ là 2 có 2 ý
nghĩa khác nhau.
Tiếp theo là mình sẽ không dùng chung tài
khoản quản trị,
cái này đương nhiên là phải phân ra để có
ai đang làm cái hành động gì để mình truy
vết và xác định cái trách nhiệm.
Rồi các cái tài khoản nghỉ việc,
chuyển vị trí phải được xử lý ngay và
không dùng thì phải bị vô hiệu hóa định
kỳ để tránh mà cái người đó không còn
quyền mà những họ.
Trong thực tế là họ không còn quyền,
nhưng mà cái hệ thống của mình không cập
nhật kịp thì nó sẽ có nhiều chuyện vấn đề
không tốt hơn.
Tiếp theo là về phân quyền thì cái quan
trọng thứ 2 để đảm bảo cái hệ thống của
mình,
hoạt động tốt và mình phải phân quyền một
cách chính xác,
xác định ai làm được cái quyền gì giống
như cái các quyền mà trên hệ thống thì
thường thường các quyền đối với các cơ sở
dữ liệu thôi.
Làm xem tạo mới chỉnh sửa xóa và quản trị.
Thực chất là mấy cái thực thao tác này là
cái thao tác trong cơ sở dữ liệu của mình
thì nó có nhiều các nguyên tắc phân quyền,
ha thì là chỉ cấp sát quyền tối thiểu khi
cần thiết,
chỉ truy cập phần thông tin cho công việc.
Và tránh một người nắm toàn bộ quy trình
quan trọng thì có một số cách triển khai
phổ biến để đảm bảo các nguyên tắc này
như là phân quyền theo cá nhân,
theo nhóm người và theo vai trò.
Nếu mà mình thực hiện tốt thì mình sẽ có
thể phê duyệt cấp quyền nhạy cảm, rà soát.
Quyền định kỳ và ghi nhận và thay đổi
quyền để kiểm tra sau này thì đối với các
hệ thống á.
Người ta hay hiện tại thì xuống chung mà
có gặp nhiều thì thấy phân quyền theo vai
trò hơn mình là tài khoản cá nhân,
mình đang nắm vai trò gì.
Thí dụ vai trò là giảng viên,
là sinh viên, là nhân viên phòng đào tạo.
Thì mình sẽ có các quyền khác nhau ha.
Tiếp theo là mình cũng phải quan tâm tới
cấu hình là tập hợp các tham số,
thiết lập và tiêu chuẩn vận hành của hệ
thống như là cấu hình máy chủ,
cấu hình mạng, cấu hình ứng dụng,
cấu hình bảo mật.
Về vì sao mình phải quản lý cấu hình này
thì nhằm để tránh sai lệch được các môi
trường hỗ trợ triển khai đồng nhất,
giảm lỗi do thay đổi tùy tiện và dễ khôi
phục khi có sự cố.
Nguyên tắc thực hiện thì mình phải có
chuẩn cấu hình ban đầu, mọi thay đổi được.
Phê duyệt phải được ghi nhận ưu tiên các
mẫu có hình chuẩn và lưu lịch sử các
phiên bản cấu hình thì cái này á là trong
cái đề án của mình lát vào các cái bước
thực hiện ấy thì mình có,
nếu mà các em xem tới mấy cái bước sau có
cái bước là.
Xây dựng tài và.
Tại hoặc tài liệu nội bộ để hướng dẫn sử
dụng á là các em cũng phải cung cấp cái
tài liệu về cấu hình này ha.
Rồi các cái nhật tiếp theo là về nhật ký
thì nhật ký nó sẽ là cái bản ghi lại cái
sự kiện xảy ra trên hệ thống thì có một
số cái loại nhật ký thường gặp như nhật
ký đăng nhập,
đăng xuất nhật ký thay đổi cấu hình nhật
ký truy cập sử dụng ứng dụng nè,
nhật ký lỗi và cảnh báo.
Báo nhật ký bảo mật.
Thì mục tiêu của mình phải theo dõi mấy
cái này nha để theo dõi hoạt động này
phát hiện bất thường,
hỗ trợ điều tra sự cố phục vụ kiểm toán
và tuân thủ là người ta kiểm toán coi cái
hệ thống mình đã được vận hành có đúng
theo yêu cầu và đúng theo quy định hay
không á.
Ngoài ra,
nếu mà bạn nào làm bên đây từ sen thì em
sẽ thấy có một số các bài toán người ta
khai thác nhật ký lớp này cho nhiều bước
khác nhau, giống như là.
Mình coi cái mức độ hài lòng hay là mức
độ tương tác của người dùng đối với hệ
thống hay mức độ học tập của sinh viên
đối với hệ thống học tập online chẳng hạn
dùng để khai thác cá nhân hóa dịch vụ.
Và để đi test ra các cái hoạt động bất
thường.
Thì trong cái dịch dữ liệu này ở bên Tây
Tan, người ta cũng hay sử dụng nhiều lắm.
Và tiếp theo là phải có cơ chế sao lưu
khôi phục là tạo bản sao lưu dữ liệu để
phòng mất mát và có cơ chế khôi phục để
phục hồi dữ liệu và dịch vụ sau khi sự cố
xảy ra thì như làm.
Cái sự cố thường có gặp như là cái mình
bị xóa nhầm, lỗi phần cứng hay gặp mã độc.
Hay có sự cố hệ thống và về thiên tai,
thiên tai có nghĩa là nó giống như cái sự
cố vừa rồi của cái đợt mà.
Đầu chiến tranh ở Trung Đông là cái hệ
thống của Amazon bị tấn công nên nếu lúc
đó ai mà sử dụng các dịch vụ của Amazon
Plow của Amazon ấy.
Thì sẽ nhận được thông báo yêu cầu mình
phải tự back up dữ liệu tại vì cái hệ
thống máy chủ nó đang gặp vấn đề về vật
lý, vật lý và thiên tai,
hệ thống chủ bị tấn công.
Thì cái đó nó cũng khá là hi hữu,
nhưng mà là sẽ có nên thường trong một
cái khi mà em đưa ra cái đề án đầu tư
mình nếu như nào có hệ thống đầu tư về
phần cứng,
về hệ thống máy chủ mà em lên trong cái
bản giữ toán.
Bán trong cái môn đoạn khoa học của mình
về em thì em mua máy chủ thì em sẽ có em
phải điều kiến số lượng máy chủ thứ nhất
là phải phân chức năng của máy chủ.
Cái thứ 2 thì là mình sẽ có máy chủ ở
nhiều nơi.
Để tránh cho cái hiện tượng thiên tai ở
một nơi thì vẫn còn cái chỗ ở nơi khác để
khôi phục lại được á.
Rồi khi mà mình nắm mấy cái phía cái
thông tin hoạt động phía trên là mình
trong cái quá trình xây dựng cái đề án
đầu tư là các em sẽ phải cung cấp các cái
tài liệu quản trị.
Xây dựng các giải pháp quản trị bảo mật
cũng như là đầu tư các thiết bị với chủ
phần cứng để đảm bảo quy trình hoạt động
của công ty, cơ quan mà các em chọn.
Và sau khi mà mình xây dựng quản trị đó
tốt rồi thì mình sẽ có một số khái niệm
như SEO.
Quay tham mấy cái đầu đo thì làm đầu đo
thông dụng được rồi có một vài nhóm đã có
sử dụng rồi đó.
Nó là một số cái độ đo cam kết,
mức độ dịch vụ đơn vị cung cấp và đơn vị
sử dụng, có nghĩa là mình cung cấp.
Mình sẽ hai bên thương lượng với nhau về
cái.
Các SLA mình sẽ đảm bảo khi mà mình bàn
giao cho họ và một số thường mình sẽ phải
cam kết như là cái mức sẵn sàng sử dụng
dịch vụ nè, thời gian phải là sự cố,
thời gian khôi phục và phạm vi hỗ trợ.
Có cái ấp Time ở đây là cấp than cam kết
của mình.
Nó là một cái loại đậu đo mình cam kết á
phụ.
Nó sẽ phải đạt từ hướng 99% hoặc 99,
9% gì đó phù hợp với các dịch vụ cơ bản
và quan trọng là các dịch vụ có yêu cầu
cao hơn chi phí lớn hơn.
Là nếu có sự cố xảy ra thì cái lúc mà
thời gian nó khôi phục lại là nhanh hay
chậm.
Thì thường các em sẽ thấy mấy cái dịch vụ
quan trọng mà chất lượng cao mà được đánh
giá tốt á thì cái thời gian mà phục hồi
khôi phục sự cố của nó sẽ nhanh hơn bình
thường rất là nhiều.
Và ngoài tiếp theo là về giám sát,
giám sát là cái quá trình theo dõi liên
tục tình trạng và cái hạ tầng về dịch vụ
thì nó sẽ giúp mình phát hiện sớm bất
thường,
cảnh báo trước khi dịch vụ bị gián đoạn,
hỗ trợ trận đấu nguyên nhân theo dõi xu
hướng.
Tải và năng lực của hệ thống thì đây là
một số các nhóm giám sát cơ bản.
Thì ở đây,
nếu mà bạn nào có đi theo đầu tư cái phần
một bản trị thì các em đưa vào cái dịch
vụ quản trị thì các tiêu chí quản trị nào?
Cái cần đặt ra thì các em có thể tham
khảo ở đây ha?
Và mình sẽ cam kết là mình sẽ giám sát
cái gì và mình sẽ lưu trữ những cái dữ
liệu giám sát gì để cung cấp cho người
dùng khi cái hệ thống được đầu tư đề đáng
và được đầu tư xong và cái hệ thống được
đưa vào vận hành.
Hỏi đây là một số cái.
Khái niệm về quy trình xử lý sự cố.
Cho giống như cái này là các em có thể
đưa cho các em tham khảo thôi và có thể
nó có mình có thể điều chỉnh cái quy
trình sự cố phù hợp hơn ha,
nhưng về cơ bản thì nó sẽ gồm có 6 búc là
cái sự cam kết của mình khi mà sự cố xảy
ra. Đó là với các thiết bị đầu tư.
Và các cái hệ thống phần mềm và dịch vụ
mình cung cấp cho họ đầu tư cho họ thì nó
có thể xử lý sự cố có thể theo 6 bước như
là phát hiện và tiếp nhận nè,
phân loại mức độ ảnh hưởng.
Phân công và xử lý thành vùng và khắc
phục tạm thời,
khôi phục dịch vụ tổng kết nguyên nhân và.
Phòng ngừa tái diễn ha.
Và mình có cái các loại,
mức sự cố cung cấp ở đây cái này là giống
như cái bảng miêu tả ban đầu để khi mà có
sự cố xảy ra mình với người dùng phân
loại các sự cố để đưa ra xử lý ha.
Như là nghiêm trọng,
gián đoạn diện rộng nè,
ảnh hưởng lớn nhưng có giải pháp tạm nè,
B3 là ảnh hưởng cục bộ,
B4 và lỗ nhỏ và yêu cầu hỗ trợ thì cái
nguyên tắc xử lý là ưu tiên khôi phục
dịch vụ trước ghi nhận đầy đủ các diễn
biến.
Không rõ ràng và cái cam kết và có cái
lót file đầy đủ để người ta kiểm định và
kiểm định và thanh tra cái hoạt động
trong hệ thống của mình,
ghi sự cố xảy ra đó.
Ừ thường là cái này nó sẽ phải có các
thông tin đầy đủ á chứ mình xây dựng cái
các cái lớp đầu tư cho người ta và có các
thành phần quản trị mà mình không cung
cấp đầy đủ mấy cái thành phần này á thì
nó không đạt ha.
Rồi có thể là quản trị tài sản nhìn nó
chung,
cái quản trị tài sản thường là các cái
tài sản công nghệ thông tin và cái quản
lý cái vòng đời và toàn bộ vòng đời.
Nếu cái này mà khi trong cái.
Dự án đầu tư để đề án đầu tư của mình thì
mình phải liệt kê đầy đủ với các tài sản
công nghệ thông tin và làm sao quản lý
vòng đời,
hỗ trợ cho cái thuốc phòng giao cho khách
hàng, nó có thông tin hướng dẫn cụ thể.
Và mục tiêu là mình **** muốn là khi mà
mình đưa ra giống như em đưa ra cái dự án
đầu tư,
cái đề án đầu tư với các thiết bị có cái
mục tiêu rõ ràng.
Và phạm vi rõ ràng.
Và nó được sử dụng quản lý ra sao,
phòng đời ra sao thì nó sẽ giúp cho người
ta cái tin tưởng mình.
Tại vì cái mục tiêu đầu tư của mình nó đã
được sử dụng tại đúng mục đích.
Và mình đã kiểm soát được chi phí và bỏ
chi phí cho mỗi thành phần,
không có tiến hành lãng phí và nó đầy đủ
các thành phần cơ để phục vụ cho hoạt
động ở công ty.
Rồi đây là các danh mục bản địa cũng có
để mình viết trong cái phần cam kết đảm
bảo rủi ro quản trị chi phí và kế hoạch
đầu tư trong cái bản của mình là mình
phải đạt được cái thông tin này nha cái.
Liệt kê đầy đủ và đầy đủ các thông tin mà
nó đạt được hết tất cả các mục tiêu mình
đặt ra.
Rồi đây là một số cái độ đo,
cô thấy đợt trước là có một số giống như
một cái độ đo để dùng để dự toán chi phí
và phân tích tài chính như là chi phí đầu
tư ban đầu nè,
chi phí vận hành định kỳ nè.
Rồi mình dự toán được cái tỷ tổng chi phí
sở hữu,
cái này là mình phải tính cho người ta
rồi mình mới báo giá ha báo giá.
Rồi khi mà mình có báo giá rồi thì mình
sẽ xây dựng cái kế hoạch triển khai theo
các cái giai đoạn để mình và cái chi phí
của mình cũng theo giai đoạn,
tại vì chi phí người ta cũng sẽ cung cấp
theo giai đoạn chứ người ta không có đưa
một hết một lần cho mình đâu.
Rồi tiêu chuẩn hóa các tài liệu và vận
hành thì cái này là nó nếu mà mình làm
cho một bên mà người ta có cái bảng tiêu
chuẩn quy định rõ ràng giống như đại học
quốc gia có bản tiêu chuẩn,
có phòng khoa học công nghệ để xây dựng
cái bảng tiêu chuẩn và từ ngữ rõ ràng thì
bị.
Buộc phải đi theo cái quy định tiêu chuẩn
và tài khoản của bên đó còn không thì
mình sẽ sử dụng các cái quy định về và
các cái tiêu chuẩn quốc tế đã được công
nhận hoặc được các cái sách cung cấp.
Chuẩn được chuẩn hóa và được nhiều người
công dụng được nhiều sử dụng,
và nó có cái tài liệu reffron.
Tài liệu của để minh chứng để cho cái
nguồn sử dụng thì sao mình sử dụng rau đo
đó nó đã được công bố và kiểm định rồi.
Và xin đổi các thì mình thay thế mấy cái
tiêu chuẩn quốc tế chung đó.
Rồi khi mà mình làm cái đó thì khi mà
chuyển hóa thì mẫu tài liệu phải thống
nhất các phiên bản lịch sử có người trách
nhiệm định kỳ.
Các cái tiêu chuẩn ở đây sẵn nó ở đây nè.
Thì.
Cô ấy luôn là trong cái bài thực hành và
đồ án của mình,
cô có các bước hướng dẫn sử dụng ở các
bước hướng dẫn thực hiện các bước hướng
dẫn thực hiện.
Thì khi mà các em thực hiện đó thì các em
sẽ có cái nguồn tài liệu.
Trung để cho mình làm cho bà thực hành và
đồ án.
Chứ nó không phải là cái mục lục nha tại
vì hồi năm rồi lúc mà cô chấm bài là cô
đã gặp rất nhiều nhóm á là các bạn làm
rất là ẩu là các bạn tổng hợp lại máy tất
cả các cái bài tập.
Quá trình về các bước nội dung mà các bạn
thực hiện ở các bước á,
các bạn gom vô báo cáo rồi hết các bạn
không duyệt lại cái báo cáo,
không chuẩn hóa báo cáo tiêu chuẩn đó là
thành một cái tiêu chuẩn thống nhất.
Rồi mà các bạn để về báo cáo luôn hả?
Thì cái đó là không đúng nha, kem.
Các em phải hiểu là các cái bước trong
tài liệu mà cô cho các em mà để các em
biết cách làm thôi.
Và các em có tài inbox đầu vào để mình
làm.
Và khi mà mình có input rồi và khi mà
mình biết tới thực hiện các bước đầy đủ
rồi á tới cái lúc em viết báo cáo tổng
hợp báo cáo đã gọi là tổng hợp báo cáo
thì em sẽ tổng hợp báo cáo theo một cái
mục luật.
Chuẩn rõ ràng và giúp cho người đọc dễ
đọc.
Hay là theo cái quy định của người ta chứ
không phải em cơ nguyên tất cả các nội
dung của em thả đó rồi kể người ta tự
động nha, các em không có cái đó đâu nha.
Cái ví dụ,
mấy cái bước này là các cái bước thường
là cái một cái đề án đầu tư hoặc là một
cái dự án phần mềm thường,
nó sẽ có luôn cô cung cấp ở đây cho các
em làm.
Nếu mà mình gặp một cái dự án khác thì có
thể nó cũng có như này hoặc nó yêu cầu
thêm thì mình làm thêm thôi và người ta
sẽ có một cái form.
Hoặc là có yêu cầu riêng.
Thì các em lúc mà các em viết cái báo cáo
phân báo cáo là phải theo cái phương báo
cáo yêu cầu riêng đó chứ không phải mình
tổng hợp lại để đó ha.
Tại vì giống như là các tài liệu mình bỏ
các bước mình làm vào cái bước giai đoạn
khác nhau thì mỗi bước đó nó mình có cách
đặt tên, thí dụ các đặt tên và độ đo quy.
Quy định về ký hiệu độ đo hoặc ký hiệu
tính toán hay quy định về cái đơn vị tính
toán đi ở mỗi đợt mình làm hơi khác nhau
xíu tại vì mình mỗi đợt mình nằm riêng
từng đợt mà thì hoặc là mỗi cái nó sẽ là
mỗi thành phần khác nhau.
Thì khi mà em tổng hợp lại là các em phải
chuẩn hóa nó lại.
Để tránh một cái hiệu mà mình đặt đặt cho
22 đơn vị khác nhau.
Một cái hiệu mình dùng nhiều lần hay là
cái một cái một,
một cái thành phần công thức đó mà mình
lại sử dụng nhiều ký hiệu khác nhau.
Nó không có thống nhất á là vài chuẩn hóa
nó lại ha.
Rồi.
Còn về tổng kết này thì là bản trị hệ
thống không chỉ là quản trị kỹ thuật mà
còn là quản trị quy trình trách nhiệm và
rủi ro cho các bên như em.
Rồi cái phần này thì các em có chỗ nào
không rõ không?
Rồi vậy bây giờ cho nó ổn rồi thì mình
giao bài tập hơn cái em.
Ở hướng dẫn thực hành và ra bài tập đầu
tiên mình sẽ vô hướng dẫn thực hành trước
hết.
Rồi bài tập hôm nay của mình là bài tập
lập kế hoạch giai đoạn 2 ha.
Để mình lúc linh trước qua đây.
Bài tập lập kế hoạch giai đoạn 2 của mình.
Là cô đã mở rồi.
Các đại diện nhóm học bài tập nộp đường
link trong tối hôm nay, trước ha.
Sau đó là em phân công công việc cho các
bạn làm.
Mình còn có vài buổi nữa là mình tới ngày
mình thi vấn đáp rồi.
Nên các em cố gắng mình hoàn thiện các
cái bài tập này theo đúng tiến độ để em.
Mà mình tổng hợp báo cáo cho nó nhanh cho
em.
Rồi đầu tiên.
Về đồ án trước đi.
Đồ án này của mình sẽ làm 4 bước tiếp
theo từ bước 5 đến bước 8.
Tiếng hay yêu cầu kỹ thuật.
Là cái này đợt trước mà bà xã trước là
mình đã xác định được phạm vi là ở đây nè.
Mình đã xác định được cái phạm vi mục
tiêu KPI mình muốn đạt.
Mình xây dựng các cái đầu tư vào các lớp
năng lực nào và các thành phần nào trong
cái lớp năng lực đó.
Và mình cũng dự kiến được cái kiến trúc
mình sẽ sử dụng luôn rồi.
Là mình đã lập luận là mình đưa ra cái
cam kết là mình muốn sử dụng cái kiến
trúc nào á.
Thì bây giờ tới cái bước số 5 là mình đã
xác mình phải đi tiếp nha các em,
hổng có phải là mỗi bước trước là mình,
thí dụ ở trước là em nói em xây dựng lớp
2, lớp 3 rồi em áp dụng kiến trúc hybrid.
Thì tới dưới đây em lại chuẩn hóa còn kỹ
thuật theo cái kiến trúc khác hoặc là cho
cái lớp khác là không được.
Phải thống nhất từ trên xuống dưới nha
các em. Thí dụ,
ở phía trên mình đã xác định được các lớp
và mình xây dựng kiến trúc nào rồi thì
mình đã dự toán được các cái.
Thành phần nào, các nhóm nhu cầu nào,
hiệu năng này, dung lượng nè,
rồi HABA nè và sugurity và ốp nào,
mình cần làm rồi,
rồi xác định được các KPA nào rồi.
Và các cái thành phần nào mình sẽ đầu tư
rồi thì bây giờ mình sẽ tổng hợp ở đây.
Chữ hóa tổng hợp lại hot theo các tiêu
chí trên.
Để mình đảm bảo rằng các yêu cầu kỹ thuật
và các tiêu chí nghiệm thu của mình sẽ
tương ứng với nhau và cái yêu cầu kỹ
thuật với cái mục tiêu ban đầu phía trên
á ở trên các em xác định mục tiêu ra sao,
các em PA như thế nào rồi thì cái yêu cầu
kỹ thuật ở đây của mình cũng.
Phải tương ứng.
Các yêu cầu kỹ thuật và các độ đo sử dụng
về các thành phần nào mình sẽ đầu tư,
nó phải thống nhất ở phía trên.
Để người ta biết vận hành ha sao và sao
khi mình có yêu cầu kỹ thuật rồi thì bây
giờ mình sẽ lập danh mục đầu tư là mình
sẽ hạn mục các mình,
mình sẽ đầu tư các cái thiết bị phần cứng
nào ha, rồi các con.
Ở trong này thì có những cái mình phải bỏ
chi phí.
Thứ nhất là các thiết bị phần cứng phải
bỏ ra mình mua nè cái phần mềm bản quyền
nè sẽ sử dụng nè cho cái cơ chế các quy
trình hoạt động nè hay là có cái cơ chế
backup monitor.
Rồi các cái dịch vụ nào mình sẽ.
Phải cung cấp cho họ giống như là mình sẽ
thiết kế triển khai cho họ như thế nào
thì em phải khai báo về một ở đây rồi chi
phí hạ tầng định kỳ là đầu tư ban đầu rồi
vận hành thì nó sẽ như thế nào ạ?
Để mình định giá.
Cái khâu này là đường giá đó,
báo giá thí vụ ở mình không có thể nói là
cái dự án này 6 tỷ xong rồi người ta sẽ
đưa 6 tỷ,
người ta còn phải biết 6 tỷ đó được.
Đọc thư như thế nào nên phải có danh mục
đầu tư rõ ràng,
sau đó mình phải dự toán chi phí dựa trên
cái danh mục đầu tư đó thì các em phải dự
toán chi phí, cái chi phí anh em mình học,
còn mình coi rồi đó để mình có các theo
các giai đoạn như là giai đoạn mua sắm
ban đầu triển khai.
Đây nè rồi các cái giai đoạn bảo trì nè,
rồi các cái vận hành rồi các lợi ích,
quy đổi vân vân thì em cần phải có cái dự
án chi phí theo từng giai đoạn.
Với mỗi giai đoạn.
Sẽ đầu tư cái mục nẻo.
Thệ và khi nếu mà mình làm đúng á.
Thì mình sẽ có kế hoạch triển khai đầy đủ
và khi mà nó, nó sẽ phải thống nhất ha.
Thí dụ,
các kế hoạch triển khai của em khi mà đầy
đủ các cái giai đoạn và khi mà tổng hợp
lại tất cả các giai đoạn này thì cái tổng
chi phí.
Cho từng giai đoạn cộng lại,
nó sẽ phải bằng tổng kinh phí mà mình đề
xuất cho họ, cho người ta.
Rồi các cái với mỗi giai đoạn này mình
đầu tư các thiết bị gì,
các thành phần gì sẽ cung cấp cái gì,
thì nó sẽ phải tương ứng với cái danh mục
và với cái chuẩn các kỹ thuật và mục tiêu.
Mà mình đã đặt ở trên.
Thí dụ ở trường mình sau khi mà thực hiện
hết tất cả các giai đoạn này,
đầu tư thì sẽ đầu tư được tất cả các
doanh đạt hết được tất cả các danh mục
sản phẩm này và các khi có đầy đủ các
danh mục sản phẩm này thì nó đã đạt được
hết mục tiêu ban đầu.
Thì cái khó của cái này là nó sẽ phải đảm
bảo tính xuyên suốt từ trên xuống dưới.
Còn cái này là cái em phân công cho nhau,
nhưng mà các em phải có một bạn kiểm tra
hoặc là các em phải thứ nhất,
nó có thứ nhất là phải thống nhất từ ban
đầu để lúc mà phân công cho các bạn,
các bạn không có làm lệch.
Và sau khi tổng hợp lại thì sẽ có người
kiểm định lại.
Chứ không là bài của mình là nó sẽ kiểu
hứa trên 1 đằng đi dưới 1 nẻo,
nó không thống nhất với nhau là khi mà
thanh tra thường là ví dụ thanh tra kiểm
toán vô đối với các đề tài của trường đại
học quốc gia,
người ta cũng thanh tra kiểm toán theo
kiểu này á.
Tại vì thí dụ có một số đề tài,
nó sẽ đi theo nhiều năm mỗi năm,
thí dụ năm nay là tới giai đoạn nào,
chi phí chi ra bao nhiêu,
chi phí chi ra bao nhiêu là chi cho những
cái mục nào. Có giấy tờ tài chính,
có cái thông tin hạng mục đầu tư rõ ràng.
Không có minh chứng hay không?
Thì minh chứng cho cái việc mình đi thi
đi dự toán ha.
Rồi tới cái chỗ mà hướng dẫn cái bài tập
ngày hôm nay tới chỗ đồ án môn học này,
đồ hương các em,
tới chỗ này không rõ luôn.
Rồi để mình đi tiếp đó,
thực hành và thực hành cũng tương tự,
thực hành thì cái nó viết dễ hơn.
Tại vì cái phạm vi, cái quy mô nó nhỏ hơn.
Rồi thực hành thì mình sẽ làm thử bước
nào tới bước chính.
Và thực hành của mình thì bữa trước là
mình nhớ là cái bài của mình nó không có
rộng,
nó chỉ đi vô một cái yêu cầu nghiệp vụ
hoặc là yêu cầu hệ thống thôi.
Thì ở đây các em cần phải xác định các
yêu cầu nghiệp vụ,
chức năng và các yêu cầu phía chức năng
mình dự kiến mà mình phải làm cho người
ta.
Để mình xây dựng cái hệ thống phần mềm áp
theo đúng cái đạt được cái yêu cầu nghiệp
vụ, yêu cầu hệ thống đó.
Xong rồi sau khi mà mình xác định được
rồi thì đương nhiên cũng sẽ quay lại
tương tự giống như cái bài đồ án là em sẽ
có cái kiến trúc tổng thể.
Nhưng mà ở đây là mình nhớ là kiến trúc
này, kiến trúc phần mềm thôi nha,
các em kiến trúc phần mềm như là theo cái
web resent này, rồi các cái application,
rồi các cái dữ liệu của mình.
Tại vì đối với hệ thống phần mềm thì nó
sẽ liên quan tới 3 thành phần này.
Bạn của anh cái hình dung này giống như
là cái.
Cái thành phần cái thành phần mà người
dùng sẽ tiếp xúc được á.
Cái dữ liệu dưới đây là cái nguồn cái này
là cái trung gian ở giữa á vậy đó.
Rồi tiếp theo về cái kế hoạch triển khai
này,
cái này nó đi xem kế hoạch triển khai hệ
thống phần mềm,
các em phải khảo sát phân tích cái quy
trình nghiệp vụ hoặc quy trình hệ thống
này ha, xong rồi các em thiết kế.
À,
phương tiện thiết kế hệ thống thông tin
rồi em phát triển, rồi em sẽ kiểm thử,
rồi em triển khai coi nó có bị lỗi hay
không, rồi tiến hành vận hành bảo trì.
Đây là theo quy trình phát triển phần mềm
thôi.
Còn nhân sự tổ chức dự án và cơ chế phối
hợp,
cái này là nó sẽ là giống như là em xây
dựng cho quy trình cho ai thì em phải
biết cái nhân sự rồi bên tổ chức dự án,
rồi các bên tham gia vào để.
Có cái cơ chế phối hợp hỗ trợ cho mình
trong quá trình phân tích hệ thống và
triển khai vận hành.
Rồi mình cũng phải dự toán chi phí giống
như cái bên bàn đồ án,
nhưng mà ở đây thì nó sẽ ít hơn.
Ví dụ ở đây các em chỉ có.
Em chỉ là hệ thống phần mềm thôi nên em
chỉ quan tâm tới cái phần lái sân nè rồi
cái phát triển nhân công để triển khai
cái hệ thống nó luôn ha rồi cái cho hạ
tầng.
Hạ tầng nó có sẵn thì mình có cần phải
thuê thêm không cho cái hệ thống phần mềm
của mình hay không?
Rồi các cái giải pháp bảo mật tuân thủ
rồi cái chi phí đào tạo chuyển giao hệ
thống phần mềm rồi vận hành.
Cái chi phí của mình tính ít hơn,
nó đỡ cái tính nhiều hơn bên kia ha.
Nhưng mà làm thì tương tự thôi,
tương tự hai cái này tương tự nhau.
Và nguyên tắc thì nó cũng giống như phía
trên.
Chi phí với mục tiêu ban đầu,
kế hoạch thực hiện ban đầu,
nó phải thống nhất từ trên xuống dưới.
Ở đây nè,
các bước phải thống nhất theo phạm vi và
mục tiêu đề tài, đề án giữ ra.
Có một mẹo khi mà cô viết mấy đề tài này
nè.
Là cô sẽ phải xác định tên đề tài.
Các cái nhóm nhân lực,
những người nhân lực nào tham gia?
Các sản phẩm nào là các sản phẩm mà tương
ứng với cây KPI nào mình sẽ làm rồi chi
phí tương ứng sẽ được trả cho tướng,
cho các KPI đó.
À, xong đâu một cái xích giảm kiểu,
một cái sức quản lý riêng hả?
Rồi đó là mình sẽ định giá được cái kinh
phí đề tài.
Sau đó để có thể tạo được cái KPI đó thì
bây giờ mình sẽ dự kiến là mình sẽ có bao
nhiêu giai đoạn làm việc với mỗi giai
đoạn sẽ phân công cái nhân lực nào vô thì
mình tại vì mình có.
Cái sinh nhân lực kế quên thì mình phân
công vô để mình tránh mình cái người có
người phân công và người đó không nằm
trong hành viên đề tài thì nó là sai đúng
không?
Thì mình phải để mấy cái đó để mình rà
soát, cho nó chính xác á.
Xong rồi với một cái giai đoạn phân công
đó thì sẽ thực hiện các yêu cầu kỹ thuật
và công việc gì mình giao là cái bia đặt
ra là gì để bàn giao lại cho cái giai
đoạn tiếp theo.
Thì em viết xong xong thì em rà soát.
Thì em những cái.
Đó là những cái nội dung quan trọng,
trang phải để gần với nhau để lúc mà
trang với cái bài của mình á mình viết để
mình so cho nó chính xác và nó không có
bị lệch.
Đó là cái mẹo để mình tránh bị sai sót
khi thực hiện viết một cái đề án học,
cái thuyết minh promoso nào cũng vậy thôi.
Rồi cái chỗ này có câu hỏi nào không các
em về cái yêu cầu bài tập này?
Rồi nếu không có câu hỏi gì,
cô giao bài tập này về cho lớp mình nha
các.
Đại diện thư ký hoặc là trưởng nhóm.
Nhớ nạp link cho cái bài này không quên
nha em.
Tới buổi sau là cái bài tập giai đoạn
cuối rồi nên mình còn có vài buổi thôi
nên ra bài tới đâu thì các em phân công
làm tới đó để một mình tổng hợp nha.
Đúng rồi sẵn đó cái đây hồi nãy cái ông.
Nói là.
Sau khi mà thực hiện tất cả các bước thì
kem phải tổng hợp chuẩn hóa thành tạo
thành một cái báo cáo.
Theo một cái form mà người ta quy định
đặt ra nếu có,
còn nếu không có form thì mình sẽ viết
sao cho người đọc chơi dễ đọc và nó phải
thống nhất các cái nội dung thực.
Hiện á thì ở đây cô có gợi ý một số cái
khung,
mục lục thường sẽ phải làm để các em viết.
Thì các em phải tổng hợp nó thành các cái
mục trong đây cho tư hướng bài viết cho
nó phù hợp.
Không có copy tập bằng cách dán mấy cái
nội dung của em làm cái bài tập em dán
thì bước một bước hai,
tới bước 12 để vô rồi để cô chấm nha cái
form một cái thuyết minh đề tài hoặc là
cái em xin kinh phí mình không có không
có ai làm kiểu đó nha các em.
Người ta sẽ có form cái người là có nghĩa
là các bước là cách mình làm.
Là cái sản phẩm nội dung mình làm xong
rồi mình phải viết thành cái form theo
cái quy trình của người ta khi mà mình
làm đề tài dự án chứ mình không có viết
theo cách của mình được.
Rồi.
Nếu không có câu hỏi nào thì bây giờ mình
giải đáp về cái.
Ngọc hai lưng gì ta?
Cái này mình không có nộp 2 linh nha các
em,
em chỉ làm tạo một cái phonder bài tập
lập kế hoạch giai đoạn 2,
trong đó là các em mình làm 2 phần.
Thì kem có thể tạo ra 2 phương đăng riêng
cho đồ án mua hộp riêng cho bài thực hành
riêng để mình làm cái bài tập các bước
của đồ án môn học,
các bước của bài thực hành như cô vô cô
trắng cho nó cô phân biệt được cái file
nào và nhớ em có phân công tổng hợp.
Hợp gì về chuyện của em nhưng mà các em
cũng phải tạo cái funder cho dễ quản lý
và cái file cuối cùng bên ngoài cái file
phái nô cuối cùng bên ngoài là phải để
bên ngoài cùng để cô nhìn vô cô biết đó
là file phái no cô chấm nha.
Rồi còn nhóm 10 nhóm 10 sau khi sửa thì
em có chỗ nào không rõ hay nhóm 10?
Nếu không có chỗ nào không rõ,
mình tự làm tiếp thì mình cứ làm thôi các
em.
Buổi sau có vấn đề thì buổi sau trao đổi
và hiệu chỉnh các giải đáp thắc mắc.
Rồi nếu không có vấn đề gì thì nhớ cái
buổi học mình hôm nay sẽ kết thúc ở đây.
Sau trình.
Anh em xin hỏi là cái bài thực hành đồ án
của nhóm.
Về sao?
tôi lại.
Để bạn đạt trình bày tại của tôi.
Dạ cô ơi
Đòi xanh.
Hiệp A coi cho em hỏi một vấn đề cái cột.
Là đây là nhóm em lúc trước cô cô kêu là.
Bên em dùng bếp.
Deepfake đúng không cô?
Tại vì em em em thấy có hay.
Nhiều nhóm lắm, em nhiều nhiều,
nhiều nhóm lắm.
Em thì bây giờ em nhiều nhóm lắm nên khi
mà các em hỏi là các em hỏi về cái ý.
Nhỡ nhóm em làm AI á.
Ví dụ em nói là cái yêu cầu là gì rồi em
làm như thế này là chỉnh sửa như vậy đúng
không? Thì cô sẽ dễ hình như.
Thích cần xem màn hình luôn cô.
Thì xe thì có thể xem.
Thì
Hiện tại lúc trước là làm cái về.
Chống chống chống giả mạo người dùng.
Ừ.
Rồi đây là nó sao em?
Thì
Hôm qua với bạn có luận sao xem là cái
đít phây.
Tức là cái kiểu như là sao cái người dùng
và dùng cái tag để chống giá mạo là người
dùng á cô.
Là em muốn tích hợp cái công nghệ đó vô
cái quá trình thực hiện các cái.
Đăng nhập người dùng xác nhận xác nhận
người dùng hay là cái các cái là vô các
Quy trình quy trình.
cái quy trình xác nhận của người dùng
acount đúng không?
Xác nhận cái người dùng.
Xác thực của bằng khuôn giống như là ý
của hỏi là phải là xác thực khuôn mặt và
Tôi khuôn mặt.
các em muốn tích hợp công nghệ deepfach
trong quy trình xác thực khuôn mặt của hệ
thống năng động đầu tư đúng không?
Nhà cũng có đây thích học in.
Là đang làm cho bài,
là em đang nói với bài thực hành đúng
đang.
không?
Ví dụ là cái sự đóng phần mềm của em,
ví dụ giống như bên em là ngân hàng vậy
đúng không?
Ngân hàng thì em.
Máy bay tín dụng.
Ở cái gì?
Đúng đúng đúng.
Ngân hàng ừ thì gặp bên ngân hàng thì em
muốn cải tiến cái dịch vụ ngân hàng an
toàn và bảo bao hơn cái mục tiêu đề tài
và thực hành của mình là các em **** muốn
xây dựng một cái hệ thống ứng dụng dịch
vụ của ngân hàng dành cho khách hàng của
mình một cách an toàn và bảo mật hơn.
Là thông cái bình thường,
cái áp dụng cái phương pháp xác thực
Nhạc.
khuôn mặt thì bây giờ mình bình thường
thay vì mình chỉ áp xác thực khuôn mặt
bình thường thì cái ứng dụng này nó có áp
dụng công nghệ deffect để chống giả mạo.
Và em dự kiến là xây dựng các hệ thống
phần mềm có tích hợp cái deffect trong
quy trình xác thực khuôn mặt người dùng
để làm tham gia dịch vụ của ngân hàng
đúng không?
Dạ,
theo hiểu là chống giả mạo khiến người
Thì.
dùng.
Ví dụ như là người tới người dùng cái mặt
nạ 3D là.
Quay gieo giả mạo người khác để chống lại
cô.
Ừ thì chống lại.
Dạ.
Thì thấy cô mô tả con khác gì nào, cô chứ,
cô mô tả có khác cái gì cái còn của các
eeack.
em đâu.
Kệ kem tìm hiểu cái công nghệ deepfake đó
các em không biết nó dùng để làm gì hả?
Là có một số cái kiểu mà ví dụ đăng nhập
bằng khuôn mặt đi.
Nhưng mà nếu mà mình không có cái công
nghệ đó thì người ta có thể sử dụng cái
Dạ.
hình chụp của cái người đó để vô nó cũng
vậy nó cũng cho nó cũng cho locking vô
thì cái đó là sai đúng không?
Dạ không.
Hoặc là sử dụng các hình ảnh,
video là sai,
bây giờ làm sao mình phải đi test được,
đó là thực sự là cái người đó đang quan
sát thông qua camera trên đăng nhập vô,
đó là một người thật đang đăng nhập vô.
Thì mình áp dụng công nghệ Deepfast để
mình detect được cái trường hợp giả mạo
đó.
Đúng không?
Thì em đang được test vô một cái quy
trình bình thường và có áp dụng công nghệ
mới để chống giả mạo.
Khi mà em chống giả mạo được thì hệ thống
nó sẽ của em,
nó sẽ được đánh giá là an toàn và bảo mật
hơn.
Và người dùng sẽ yên tâm khi sử dụng hơn.
Người ta không sợ bị cái người nào đó giả
danh vô rút tiền của mình đi hết chẳng
hạn.
Yeah.
Thì mình lập luận rồi mình làm vậy thôi
chứ thì cái ý tưởng nó là vậy đó em.
Chứ các em lăn tăn chỗ nào?
Tụi em đang tăng chỗ mà nó tiếp tiếp phây.
Thì đó là công nghệ của em áp dụng mà chứ
đâu có gì.
Công nghệ được tích hợp vô hệ thống phần
mềm của các em.
Chứ em nghĩ mấy công nghệ đó chạy độc lập
hả?
Biết thay những lời viết tắt của cô.
Tụi em đang lăn tăn cái đó.
Là lăn tăn cái gì á?
Là không biết công nghệ đó áp dụng được
cái quy trình mình có hợp lý hay không
hay làm sao chứ các em cứ nói lăn tăn thì
làm sao cô biết giải thích.
Các em hình như mấy câu nói không,
thí dụ em lăn tăn là em không biết cái kỹ
thuật này á,
nó sẽ được vận dụng trong cái ngữ cảnh
ứng dụng này có được không hay cô không?
Hay cô thì các em nếu mà các em thắc mắc
á, ví dụ em xây dựng hệ thống phần mềm.
Các em nói là em yêu cầu về cái bạn yêu
cầu của bạn thực hành áp dụng công nghệ
mới thì công nghệ mới em chọn là deepfast.
Và bây giờ em đang thắc mắc là không biết
cái dext của em áp dụng vô cái quy trình
này. Vậy là em áp dụng được hay không?
Thích hợp cho đúng hay không?
Thì các em chỉ có nếu mà có thắc mắc thì
chỉ có thể thắc mắc chỗ đó thôi chứ làm
sao ta.
Thì cô diễn giả nãy giờ là nó dùng ứng
dụng vô được.
Chứ các em thắc mắc cái gì?
Có thể diễn giải rõ là người.
Chứ em mình có đặt mấy câu hỏi luôn kiểu
ngắn gọn,
rồi người nghe hoặc là cái người hướng
dẫn là sẽ không biết là em đang muốn làm
cái gì thì khó diễn giải lắm, cái em.
Kèo vậy, tôi tin tổng hợp của sao lại.
Nhà cô xem bạn nhốt dùm em.
Hỏi cái vấn đề em tại cái báo cáo tiến
trình nó đã qua rồi,
Để anh nhóm em.
không có nhóm nào cô cũng sẽ coi có không
có đủ phải là mình muốn cô đưa coi vào
thời điểm nào cũng được vào những cái
giai đoạn giống như là báo cáo tiến trình
mà cô.
Trải qua 2 đợt báo cáo tiến trình rồi thì
lúc mà cái báo cáo tiến trình đó thì cô
sẽ coi cái bài của mình để cô sửa hết
từng phần.
Còn nếu mình qua giai đoạn đó rồi mình đã
nhận được góp ý,
mình hiểu chỉnh sửa đó thì là các em hiệu
chỉnh và trong cái quá trình viết á cái
chỗ nào không rõ thì các em hỏi.
Để cô hướng dẫn để các em tự để có thể tự
hoàn thiện.
Hình như biết cách làm không,
biết cách vận hành chưa?
Là các em muốn áp dụng công nghệ để chống
cái đó hay là sao cô không hiểu.
Hay là em muốn.
Ý bạn là đang dùng áp dụng depace để
chống lại cái depack đó.
À.
Thì là ứng dụng được mà.
Thì sẽ tin là chi sợ gì.
Dạ có ý là tụi em đang thắc mắc là mình
có 2 hướng,
Ừ.
một là ứng dụng công nghệ Deepfake để
chống deffect hay là mình đang làm công
Ừ.
nghệ deepfax.
Em thấy cô dùng thuật ngữ là công nghệ
deepack thì em không biết có em có đang
hiểu sai gì không nên là em có 2 cái
hướng đó.
À,
nhưng mà thường là người ta hay cái đíp
phây thường là người ta đang làm và người
ta đang muốn chống giả mạo, chống cái.
Không tại tại em nghe bị ngu.
Tận deffect nên ở đây cô khi mà cô đang
nói á là cô không biết là cô có phát âm
nhầm hay là nói là cái em bị rối không?
Nhưng mà là ý cô nói là áp dụng các công
nghệ để mình chống cái deffect.
Thương hai người ta gọi nói chung là
chống đi phét, chống bị cái giả mạo đó.
Hình ảnh giả mạo rồi cái hệ thống nó
không phân biệt được đó là cái tấm ảnh.
Hay là cái video giả mạo thôi.
Sống trong gia tăng.
Ừ, đúng rồi, cháu nghe mọi người dùng.
Để chí thập thép thép.
Ừ nhưng mà ý nó là có cái số hiện tại là
người ta đang dùng defer để người ta làm
giả mạo nhiều nên thường thường á trong
một số cái ứng dụng hiện tại,
đợt rồi có một số các bạn làm hết,
các bạn viết chung là chống defact,
áp dụng công nghệ chống deffect.
Đi chung nghĩa.
Cái kem của nhìn sao?
Các em nhìn sao.
Dạ a, tại vì tụi em,
tụi em nghe ý là em tiếng anh của em
không được tốt á, em nghe,
em nghe là Deepfake,
với lại em nghe nhầm hàng Deepfake,
bạn em nghe là Deepfake nên là tụi em có
bắt đồng quan điểm.
Chút xíu là cột.
Là bạn bạn em nghe đúng em nghe sai.
Chứ sao.
Có khi cô đang nói thuận nói hai cái từ
tại cái ngữ cảnh nó là hai cái đó sử dụng
chống lại lẫn nhau nên có thể nói là nghe
một hồi các em bị nhầm á,
nhưng thực chất là chỉ là chống giả mạo
thôi. Mục tiêu của nó là chống giả mạo.
Thì thường cái đó là Face ID á,
nó hay dùng á,
face đi nó hay dùng thì hiện tại là.
Làm sao cho cái nếu mà mình sử dụng cái
ứng dụng fan ID của mình an toàn,
nó không có.
Nó không bị trao quyền đăng nhập sai cho
đối tượng giả mạo khi người ta sử dụng
các công nghệ công nghệ cao.
Và thường cái công nghệ cao ở đây là
người ta hay.
Và cái người ta muốn chống lại thì gọi là
deepface.
Nó lại chắc nó nó nó để phân biệt 2 cái
ha ừm.
Rồi các em đang làm theo hướng đó đúng
không?
Hiện A,
tụi em làm theo hướng là dùng theo hướng
là đít phây để chống đứt khác là đúng
không?
Ở đúng rồi, đúng rồi.
Giữa A và tụi em sẽ đi sâu vào cái vòng
công nghệ và các bài toán như chúng tôi
nói là những KPI là liên quan tới công
thức tính công thức,
tính chi phí này kia đúng không?
Những camera liên quan tới ý là.
Tại sao ta là cô la sao ta cô không cái
nào ta em nói lại cô nghe không muốn kì
không kịp.
Nếu như là bây giờ tụi em không bỏ tụi em
là bị say ngay,
còn KPI là cái KPI của em là đang theo
hướng là nhiều lớp.
Thì khi mà tụi em đã xác định được là sẽ
đi theo hướng là đi vay.
Tiếp khách thì KPI của em.
Cây bị cây cây đa nhiều lớp là sao ta.
Nhiều nhóm quá.
Dạ không?
Tại vì trước trước là em sẽ đi tách ra,
ví dụ như lớp AI của em,
của em là đi nguyên một quy trình á là
KPI của lớp xe, bỏ lớp bảo mật.
Ngày mai của lớp AI Kyrini chỉ ký nghĩa.
À cái bây giờ là trong cái phần mềm của
mình, mình không có lấy KPI đó em,
thí dụ em áp dụng công nghệ mới á trong
hệ thống phần mềm thì em sẽ có một số KPI
để mình chứng minh cái gồm có 2 loại KPI,
một KPI.
Là bên phần mềm á là mình đảm bảo cái hệ
thống phần mềm mình triển khai vận hành
được vận hành tốt và một nhưng mà khi mà
em áp dụng công nghệ mới thì nó sẽ có một
cái nhóm KPI riêng để chứng minh cái mức
độ hiệu quả khi em áp dụng các công nghệ
mới đó.
Em, các nhóm khác hình dung thí dụ,
thí dụ có,
thí dụ em áp dụng công nghệ mới ở đây của
em áp dụng Big Face để chống deffect đi
ha.
Thì bây giờ em chống được khoảng bao
nhiêu phần trăm?
Thì nó có sẽ có nhiều đôi đầu đo,
ví dụ dạ sự đầu đo thống kê sử dụng nhiều
nhất là cái tỷ lệ chống đúng, chống được,
chống đạt tỷ lệ cho detect đúng,
có nghĩa là mình xây dựng cái model của
mình detect đúng được những trường hợp.
Gian lận trong thí dụ trong 100 cái
trường hợp gồm có Giang có Giang có giả
mạo và không giả mạo đi thì mình test
đúng được hết đúng 100 trường hợp đó luôn
thì người ta gọi là độ chính xác 100%.
Nhưng mà thí dụ trong 100 trường hợp mình
dự đoán đúng có 90 trường hợp thôi thì
cái đồng nghĩa là độ chính xác mình 90%.
Còn nếu mà mình tích vị trí sinh cũng gọi
là độ chính xác,
nhưng mà là độ chính xác theo lớp mục
tiêu.
Thí dụ lớp mục tiêu của mình là lớp giả
mạo. Giả sử trong 100 trường hợp giả mạo.
Và cái phần mềm ứng dụng công nghệ mới
của em á chống được là nó sẽ de test ra
được trong 20 trường hợp giả mạo đó,
nó nhận diện được khoảng 15 trường hợp.
Thì lúc đó cái resin của mình sẽ tính từ
10 năm chia cho 20%.
10 năm trên 20 tính ra tỷ lệ phần trăm
thì cái tỉnh lại nó cũng ổn.
Anh đi hôm đó là mấy cái đậu đo mà thông
thường thì dùng cơ bản,
nhưng mà tùy theo mỗi bài toán sẽ có cái
độ đo khác nhau.
Nhiều độ đo lắm thì nó sẽ tùy theo cái
công nghệ và cái bài toán khoa học mà em
muốn đặt ra.
Để em đánh giá cái mức độ cái hệ thống
của em sử dụng công nghệ mới,
công nghệ mới nó hoạt động tốt hay không
thì nó sẽ có một cái bộ KPI riêng.
Cái em muốn chọn KPI thì các em phải chọn
hay. Hay tách 2 nhóm KPI đó.
KP 2 phần mềm vận dụng vận hành bình
thường và KPI của Moral.
Thí dụ em đang ứng dụng Model AI,
em xây dựng cái đó là giống như là đang
muốn xây dựng một cái model AI tự động,
bị test được những trường hợp giả mạo khi
mà người ta sử dụng các công nghệ cao,
ví dụ như deepfast để giả mạo đúng không?
Cám ơn nhóm 10.
Ừ ừ WVI là em tắt cho 2 cái nhóm KPI đó.
Nhóm 4
Tên địch với mùa xong rồi đúng không?
Nhật Bản
Dạ cô ơi, còn cái phần.
Dạ dạ, anh cảm ơn anh.
Tên đề tài xây dựng giải pháp ứng dụng
trí tuệ nhân tạo hỗ trợ,
dự báo nhu cầu và lập kế hoạch tồn kho
theo thời tiết.
Và khu vực cho FPT lớp Minh Châu.
Ai bổ sung dữ liệu thời tiết phục vụ và
đặc điểm của một hệ thống dự báo nhu cầu
hiện có của FPT Đông Châu nhằm nâng cao
độ chính xác dự báo, hỗ trợ lập kế.
Hạch danh mục quà tồn kho phù hợp với
từng nhà thuốc.
Là cái bài này của em là tập trung vào dự
báo nhu cầu.
Còn cái hỗ trợ lập kế hoạch kiểu là mình
đưa ra cái dự báo nhu cầu,
còn lập kế hoạch là người ta là chỉ để hỗ
trợ thôi.
Thí dụ mình cung cấp các thông số thống
kê hiện có và các cái chỉ số dự báo hiện
có.
Để cho người ta để cho cái đi nhà BA nhà
bên BA.
Tự lập cái hỗ trợ lập cái họ tốt hơn thôi
đúng không?
Nếu muốn.
Dạ đúng rồi,
cô sẽ hiển thị lên màn hình xây dựng cái
kết quang cho người quản trị xong rồi chỉ
hiển thị thông tin để người quản trị,
hỗ trợ người quản trị lập kế hoạch ạ.
Ok được.
Dạ, em cảm ơn cô.
Rồi còn vấn đề nào nữa không cái?